reunimos a siete parejas somos parejas
somos parejas somos somos pareja y
una de las parejas son hermanos si el
grupo descubre quiénes son se llevarán
un premio en efectivo
si no lo descubren los hermanos se
ganarán el premio cuál es la pareja el
impostor seis parejas versus dos
hermanos para mantener el nivel de
equidad no tocarse ni besarse empecemos
con las fechas importantes desde cuando
están juntos cuando cumplen
depende siempre qué crees que sea lo
mejor de tu pareja es raro decir eso de
un hermano si soy sincero pienso que
tiene una gran personalidad tampoco me
gustaría decir que mi hermana está de
buena entiendo eso está genial a mí me
encanta su creatividad es un hombre
brillante su valor me gusta su valor con
sus dientes
sé que no lo pueden ver pero ella tiene
algo grande y adentro
cuál es su posición sexual favorita ella
va con todo era de misionera si la del
misionero me gusta y también bueno
nosotros no usamos correas ni nada ahora
entiendo cómo lo hacemos lo digo por mí
y por él creo que lo prefiere así para
no tener que hacer el trabajo
la mayor parte del trabajo por lo
general cuando ella está boca arriba y
en sus ojos ahí esa conexión emocional
mientras haces el trabajo es muy cierto
mi hijo tiene es tienes mi foto
el estilo perrito cualquier cosa por
detrás es mucho mejor bueno podemos
decir muchas cosas buenas de nuestra
pareja pero qué es lo que más les
molesta realmente él no pone nada donde
debe ir
cada comida no me gusta cuando en la
mañana tratas de besarme
hay que pensarse siempre
voten seguidores quienes son hermanos
[Música]
sino pesas a tu pareja te delatas de
lazarte de latas
[Música]
hay un empate y el empate entre mía y
rose reina y peter cada uno de ustedes
tiene 20 segundos para exponer su caso y
en primero ella tiene tatuado mi nombre
así definitivamente cuando vi tanto que
pensé que podría hacer cualquier cosa
con un marcador bolígrafo no sé qué más
puedo decir que lo hicimos eso se
menciona en nosotros también lo hicimos
anoche y esta mañana y nos gusta la
misma ropa como pueden ver quieres decir
algo
del perrito
[Risas]
ah
buena suerte está
bien tengo una pregunta cuando supieron
que estaban listos para hacerlo en qué
momento de su relación en la primera
cita no
decirlo sino lo diferente para los
heterosexuales sabes a qué me refiero sí
nos conocimos y lo hicimos y luego cuál
es tu nombre
[Risas]
quiero decir eso no es normal y qué fue
lo que te hizo querer seguir a luego
luego nos volvimos a ver en grinder
saben qué es eso
[Risas]
me dijeron dónde queda si en los ángeles
la gente es falsa pero también conoces a
gente muy agradable y muy amigable sí
son muy sensuales
quiero saber cómo se conocieron si bien
nos conocimos en la secundaria a través
de mi mejor amiga porque él era la única
persona que podía conducir en ese
momento se enamoró de él y luego se
enamoró de mí y me invitó a salir y lo
hicimos en la primera cita esa misma
noche
ellos dos son hermanos terrible tengo
una vivimos todos juntos verdad entonces
si estás acostado en su cama en qué lado
de la cama estás sí duele del lado
derecho levanta la mano a las 3 y 1 2 3
yo es un poco raro porque todo es una
bebería es mi lado 15 años entonces
entonces ella duerme en la cama de las
hadas como se conoce nos conocimos en la
secundaria yo estaba en segundo año tú
eras mayor
[Risas]
éramos muy buenos amigos al principio y
luego no tuvimos sexo mientras éramos
amigos de hecho estaban un par de meses
antes de siquiera tener sexo sí cómo se
llevan con sus padres cuáles son sus
nombre mamá se llama carolina y su papá
se llama joseph su mamá se llama carmen
y su papá es con su mamá se llama united
y su papá se llama trong muy bien y los
suyos su papá se llama toy diablos no
recuerdo su mamá
y su papá
malvina y tomás en mont y cloud de ron y
lis
tengo amigos gays y siempre dicen no
salgo con alguien más guapo que yo ambos
son iguales se ven muy atractivos
[Música]
li pero olvidó el nombre de la mamá de
dana
y ellos creen que somos hermanos no es
posible
para hacemos hermanos peter parecía tan
indiferente algo como no me importa pero
eran tan sinceros el uno con el otro y
sus respuestas tan caóticas que seguro
no son pareja levanten la mano si creen
que la pareja en post ahora sigue en la
caja y les gustaría seguir en el juego
a partir de ahora cada vez que voten por
una pareja que no sea la impostora se
reducirá el premio total quiero
preguntarle a cada pareja si si alguno
de ustedes o ambos podría explicarnos
cuáles fueron sus vacaciones favoritas
que tuvieron juntos nuestra luna de miel
fue en cabo todo es cuestión de sexo
nosotros lo estábamos esperando nos
encantó tener sexo en la luna de miel
fue genial
ellos no tuvieron sexo hasta su luna ven
bueno soy cristiano y cuando empezamos
le dije es importante que cuando nos
casemos tengamos las mismas creencias
suena como una historia romántica más de
lo que pase sobre todo en los ángeles
viajen en los ángeles no esperar hasta
el matrimonio para evitar preguntas
sobre sexo es estratégico la razón por
la que voté por quedarme es porque soy
un poco suspicaz con ustedes también
parecen ser algo así como medio hermanas
o quizás hermanastras no lo sé estoy
siendo suspicaz como se conocieran yo
soy mamá adolescente tuve a mi hija a
los 15 años ambas tenemos drogadictos y
yo estaba en un lugar muy oscuro
me enviaron en un tratamiento en anaheim
los conocí somos lesbianas pero ella
está criando mi hija conmigo yo creo que
ya nos deshicimos de la pareja impostora
yo también lo quería porque no se besan
en la mañana
eso me molestó creen que están con el
indicado civil y por supuesto sin duda
he aguantado mucho oigan tienen hijos
están casados estuve embarazada de dos
abortos yo
estoy diciendo la verdad así me pasó
ahogando sobre la pareja si todavía está
aquí podría ser ustedes dos sí porque
ellos podrían ser hermanos pero no lo sé
ustedes de parecer a mente
alma y yo me llamo george mis padres me
pusieron alma porque dios
y ella dijo que sus padres le pusieron
alma y a helios y eso no me sonó bien
estaba esperando para decir eso
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno
levanten la mano si creen que la pareja
impostora sigue en la caja y les
gustaría seguir en el juego en la
tercera ronda asumí que peter y dina
eran hermanos pero cuando fueron
eliminados dije yo pedía que fuera fácil
ganamos ya lo sacas y que el juego
termina ahora si las luces se tornan
verdes eliminaron a la pareja y ganan si
las luces se tornan rojas entonces la
pareja sigue en la caja y pierden
demonios
la pareja puede dar un paso al frente en
3 2 y 1
me siento traicionada por michael y zac
se sentía una gran unión entre ellos y
le vimos haberlo notado
tenemos tatuado mario y luigi por favor
no
querían comer más
son hermanos de verdad
como nos dimos cuenta de que se parecían
y en su aniversario se equivocaron de
fecha
pero ya sabes no les mentiré esperaba
que nos eliminaran de primeros a él ya
mí nos gusta hablar somos molestos
gracias a dios no nos hicieron que nos
pensáramos porque lo habíamos hecho no
creo que me atraiga a alguien que se
parezca a mí es como cómo mirar a mi
hermano y decir oh que atractiva
nosotras nos han dicho que nos parecemos
mucho y eso me hace sentir incómoda a mí
me atraen los que se parecen a mí porque
me gusta cómo me veo tanto tiempo juntos
nos fundimos el uno con el otro el él
tiene un rostro hermoso pero nunca si
nunca he podido leer a michael por más
de uno démosle un beso
[Risas]
[Música]
[Aplausos]